welcome to play today today three women  is gonna cook the beef bourgino  I'm Jean my name is Teresa AKA Freedom  my name is Samantha I made a fresh beef  Bogan heal added lots of veggies  culinary Picasso I'm looking for someone  cultured I think that's what I've been  missing this is my fresh take of beef  bourguignon no mashed potatoes on that  plate it means that the person goes to  the essential what do you think about  that I agree oh wow yeah you can see he  really likes it well cooked well  seasoned the meat is really tender it  brings a lot of confidence to be able to  like just cook the principal dish  without bringing any side I think it's  on point with the confidence though you  are very direct I am I pride myself on  being here  [Music]